a lot of us have gotten to the end of
anthem and we're trying to engage in the
strong holes the free rooms the events
legendary contracts the chase valor
whatever but there's a lot of things
going kind of going wrong what could
they do right now to make this game
better starting with endgame just
chasing for loot is fine because that's
what I like to do right but when you
don't have that many places to do it and
you're kind of repeating let's say the
same strongholds over and over it kind
of gets a little bit old and yeah
there's legendary contracts and you can
free roam but I don't know what it is
about anthem specifically and in in the
game that exists today that isn't
getting me to like keep playing it like
I did with like destiny or with Diablo
which are you know similar in style in
terms of like Luke chase right and
trying to like increase your you know
power level and your gear so yeah my
answer to that would be if we want to
just say compared to destiny which i
think is reductive but for this argument
I think destiny has the advantage of
having like a steady flow like you can
be in orbit and you can launch straight
to a mission and you can get into a
groove with it whereas anthem I feel
like yours being stopped and started all
the time you return to for Tarsus or to
the launch Bay after every mission and
so to answer the question of what could
improve like I would like the equivalent
of orbit like go to a Strider or
something and be able to launch a new
mission from there because I feel like
I'm like okay ten minutes of waiting
around for people to accomplish things
or go to the bathroom because my friends
are always like well hold on I'll take
this opportunity to go to the bathroom
no game is so choppy that it's hard to
feel good after accomplishing something
and I think to build on that point and I
didn't really even think about that
frustration until now is like another
point that I think many people have said
is you know you're getting all this loot
while you're playing right but you can't
actually see or use or try anything
until you go back to port Tarsus right
you have to go back and go okay cool I
got a master work weapon SiC let's go
try it out and
you're like Oh actually I don't like
this yeah so guess what I got to go back
to port Tarsus swap my loadout again and
be like oh okay yeah like there's all
these little quality of life things that
I think they can add but endgame
specifically like destiny had a trade
right like it had something for you to
do all these dungeons to try to get
stronger to potentially do the raid
right and I know that in anthem they're
gonna have eventually like raid like
activities not specifically a raid maybe
like down the road down the road so I'm
curious to see what that is
I hope cataclysms which I think are
coming in March are gonna be a little
bit more than what I think they are
because I they kind of did like that
mini event during the the demo which was
like oh there's just Titan spawning in
the world and there's a storm and then I
was like cool I killed one is that it so
kind of rounding up what both you guys
are getting at it's like it's like
destiny you need to be able to get into
this game you need to be able to
immediately see what you're trying to do
that night like destiny is a really good
loop I know you know you know what
you're gonna do in a in an hour you know
what you're gonna do in a half an hour
you know what you're gonna do in 15
minutes and you kind of know what to
expect out of it and so a lot of stuff
is so buried in the menus and anthem
that all like one things they need to do
right away is just bring everything up
to the the front of the menu like you've
log in you know exactly what you're
chasing you know why you're chasing it
you know what you're gonna get and then
like what you said it takes you into the
freedom room they need to not keep
taking you back to for Tarsus yeah the
end game just needs to be you're in free
roam you go to a stronghold you come
back to free roam you hit a button you
mess with your loadout preferably
without a loading screen just like let
you get into that flow like so many of
the things they need to do in this game
are just let you play the game yeah and
I think like to your point I think
better challenge tracking would
accomplish a lot like I think they did a
lot to fix the challenge of the
Legionnaires like the tune sequence
because when I did it I had to do it
separately from everybody because like
opening your teammates chest or opening
a chest didn't count for your teammates
and they fixed that part which is a very
good improvement but I think like I'm
still
you have to I think go into one menu and
then a separate tab and then one more
tab before you get to what how your
progress is in that challenge and so I
guess the idea is that you could just
kind of complete them automatically but
I was struggling a lot with multi kills
because I was playing as Ranger and then
interceptor and it's much easier is like
storm to get multi kills I think it's
five enemies dying like a very close
amount of time and so I just struggled
so much and so I just had to keep
checking like did that count as most
kill did that one count
it kept not counting and I had to keep
going to that menu so I was pretty
frustrating and I think just being able
to see at a glance like what am I going
after today or what am I going after
this week when I'm checking in
so like let's say you're climbing the
Loon Mountain yeah I love it
climbing Loon Mountain what do you in
the endgame right now what are you
climbing for well you're climbing
specifically to try to get legendary
stuff you know like that's I think for
me at least is powerful level like 47
which is you know to higher than
masterwork so you're trying to you know
increase your gear score so that you can
do you know Grand Master to Grand Master
3 because those difficult ramps up right
and so you need to be higher level and
have better components better gear so a
lot of it is I still don't have some of
the masterwork weapons I think the
masterwork weapons are actually really
cool I wish they had them earlier in the
game like mid game just throughout story
like you can have a lower level version
kind of like a la I hate to keep using
destiny as an example but like you know
when you got graviton Lance or sunshine
you felt really cool and powerful in the
moment and that would have helped my
experience get to the endgame and then
want to find the better version of that
like I had no incentive to even go after
masterwork weapons by the time I got to
the point where I could get them that I
just like haven't even bothered like I
there's no reason especially because a
lot of the weapons don't feel that good
like if shotguns felt better to use and
felt like they actually did something
I'd be more interested in chasing after
a master weapon I think I'm like an
ability is another thing at the
abilities are really cool and I would
have more incentive to get those but I
yeah you just feel like you don't get
that carrot early enough to pull you
through that mid game slump that you can
get into yeah the master work weapons
are pretty cool though so I would say
like if you can like bear it like go
back because there are a few that have
unique properties and they do cool
things like one of the pulse rifles I
forget the name right now like every
time you hit the crit spot it'll also
cause an explosion so like you'll see
like like kinda and then there's like a
scout rifle that does like lightning
bolt like you know 33% chance so that's
the stuff that interests me so and then
and then also just trying to you know
get out your let's say storm for example
a specific way but you kind of have to
get lucky with component drops right you
have to hope to get the ones you
actually want to use because you can
still get other ones that like will help
your like shield and armor and
like that's good but like the ones I
want don't always drop and like they've
been tweaking and like tweaking all the
drops like it was like pretty high for
me at one point and it feels like they
nerfed them and they're not as good and
now they're gonna tweak them again I
think so it's just this forever chase
for loot and it's if you want to chase
for loot right because there's not a
reason necessarily to chase where the
loot other than knowing that you have
the better higher number and then
possibly having some gear that you
didn't have before it definitely feels
like they need more strongholds like you
need you need that thing that you're
always trying to get to to pull you
through an endgame and without a raid
right now they just need more
strongholds but also when you're getting
ready for that thing they need an easier
way for you to know what's going on with
your character like you were saying you
put on a bunch of gear but there's no
like global stat that is just telling
you how it's modifying your character
overall because some of the master works
are not as good as some of the lower
level stuff because of because of their
roles yeah it just depends on like what
you have like you could have something
that's like a purple like epic tier that
you know adds 35% elemental damage as a
storm right which is like oh that's
really good because I'm using my
abilities a lot versus like Oh only your
lightning does more damage and maybe
you're not even running lightning right
so it's tough but that's part of the
that's part of like the reason to chase
it's just as I mentioned do you want to
chase for that do you want to chase for
perfection
that's like min maxing is what we what I
say a lot didn't even like Diablo is
like you're basically trying to kid out
your javelin to the absolute best that
it can be because on top of just like
the master or we're rolling right you're
like oh I also want these other
modifiers on the master word component
to be like the best that they can be
like I want plus elemental damage or I
want my lb or RV to do more damage not
have 10% you know marksman ammo or like
you know like if you're not using those
weapons it's kind of like a useless stat
yeah definitely I think I would be more
interested in chasing that if I had like
different strongholds to try or like
something to use those weapons and
abilities on to like take advantage of
kitted out javelin because like instead
of my review I think you have those cool
abilities and know where to go with them
at the end like I don't think Titan
fights are that interesting I think
they're kind of frustrating honestly and
so I would like to see like a more
inventive boss or like you know the
strongholds like the one with the the
laser robot we get to shoot the fans I
was I didn't not like that one very much
that means you don't like 1/3 of this
room yeah I think yeah if there it's I
don't want to see more content because
that's that's too simplistic I just
think if there are something more
interesting to do then even repeating it
wouldn't be a problem but I don't want
to repeat that once wrong a whole bunch
of times to get to how many is it 50
that you have to get or something like
to do a bunch so once you complete those
challenges you have to go back to for
Tarsus what do you want to do in for
Tarsus because this is this is like we
brought this up earlier like it it I
mean yeah what do you want to do in for
Tarsus I think it is BS that everyone
flirts with you and you can't flirt back
I think that's just garbage that is an
insult to Bioware's past and I think it
would make a lot of sex everyone for the
mechanic flirts with you the Christian
Sholes character is like questionably
flirting with you
you know people people are interested in
you freelancer and I want to be able to
say flirty things back to them if I so
choose not to the guy who's always
talking about laundry and stuff though I
want to be mean to him
because I think it's funny cuz you care
just like a blanket mean to him but I I
think you know I don't even need romance
I don't even need whole romance arts I
just think it would be fun to have some
like actual banter with then nothing
wrong with diving in right sexy danger
anyway okay so fighting the Titans in
the end game can be kind of frustrating
and there's a little I mean there's a
lot of things in this game that just
feel like maybe there shouldn't be an
end game is this a game that needs an
end game I think that's like a big
question right now where do you go from
here yeah I mean I think that it doesn't
even necessarily need to be a looot game
in general like
I feels like the loot part is really
conflicting with the story part and I
think they make each other worse so I
question if this game even if it even
makes sense for it to be loot focused
because I I don't think combat has the
the tight enough feeling like I thought
you you're not in and out the game
doesn't have like the right flow I think
it focused on one or the other it would
make more sense but I don't think the
two go together very well
the flights really awesome yeah flight
is really awesome I think like but that
doesn't have to be in an in-game sense
or in a looot game sense right like like
I would just like flight I would like
people to fly a little bit longer like
even with like a pretty good heatsink I
felt like I was stopping a lot that's
just the one thing I want like I would
love to just fly and explore and not
have to worry about like finding the
loot or alternatively and like focus on
story stuff or alternatively forget
story have it be a background that just
supports the missions you're doing and
you go off and you find new loot like I
just think the way it's set up right now
I think maybe it could work like I think
those two things could work together but
right now I don't know how you walk it
back from where anthem is and how it's
hard to play with your friends and it's
hard to you end up talking over each
other and I don't have time to go and
read the well I would call it a codex
but it's called the cortex for some
reason and then you know talk to
character I just don't think that the
whole thing works so I question whether
it even needs an in-game like you said
it's hard to get around thinking about
the fact that every game has hard
settings and like does it even justify
using the word endgame just to play it
on a harder difficulty like every game
has a harder difficulty we call that a
New Game+ yeah and and they're had they
have a DLC model where apparently
they're just gonna you know it's games a
service but they're just gonna keep
putting content out like is this endgame
or is this just traditional game making
here's the game here's a harder mode
here's some new content and every couple
of months I mean it's endgame in the
sense that this is the end of this game
right like I didn't like pre this
content coming out it's what you do
after story right it's it's there if you
want to do harder difficulties and chase
loot i i'm the terrible person who likes
luce so i'm like the person they're
targeting clearly well we've all had our
fun with those games like yeah well I
still did it anyway and like I even said
in our selection I'm like alright whose
level what cuz I just want to be the
highest you know and that was my
motivating factor and I don't know I I
think it's there's interesting layers
there with the loot it's just getting
there is kind of tough and then trying
to like min/max it you just have to
really want to put in the hours to do it
and because there's only like three
strongholds there's only so much to do
it kind of makes it harder for me to
want to like do that yeah I agree
so badly I've been some punching bad
choice sexy bad choice what not
important what needs to happen to fix
this
[Music]